I had no idea how I was gonna return
this lost iPhone but by god I was
determined to figure it out I went out
to Long Island this weekend with my
girlfriend and Sunday evening we jumped
on a train to head back into New York
City right away we noticed an iPhone
wedged between the seat and the wall now
we could have given the phone to a
conductor but we had more than two hours
to kill and I started thinking WWE dee
dee what would Ellen DeGeneres do my
girlfriend Stephanie starts googling
what to do if you find a lost iPhone but
if the phone is locked and the owner
never filled out the emergency info and
there's very few options outside of Siri
this iPhone
we ask Siri anything we can think of
Siri call home Siri call mom dad Michael
Emilie Arnold anything but Siri has
nothing that matches navigate home
Stephani then ask Siri to dial the most
recent call so series based on audio
calls Ryan's cell so we asked Siri to
text Ryan's cell and dictate the message
word-for-word because remember we can't
unlock the phone we asked Ryan's cell to
call the number of the lost phone so we
can swap info
I then start to think about the iCloud
if the phone owner has his photos
connected to the cloud then he'll see
any photo or video I take I had access
to the camera so I send a message
hopefully your iCloud is on and this
videos of you but it doesn't matter a
few minutes later Ryan cell calls the
phone okay well can I get your phone
number right now second to you Ryan
turns out is the best friend of the
phone owner whose name is Kirk and lives
in the town of Bay Shore which is
halfway between where we left and we're
Stephanie and I live in New York City I
text Ryan so he has my number please for
my info along to Kirk or Kurt it was a
loud train I couldn't really hear the
name Ryan passes the info to Kirk about
40 minutes into our train ride I get a
text message from a Chris they hear you
have my husband's phone I tell her our
next stop is Bay Shore but I'm not able
to get off the train
Dreamcoat now why couldn't I get off the
train for one you can wait up to an hour
for a train on the LIRR - it was raining
and it was cold I was trying to do a
nice deed I wasn't trying to get
pneumonia three we had our cat with us
who was already hating life because he
hates traveling we'll be there in the
next two minutes she texts I live two
minutes away they do a handoff the Train
finally pulls up and I poked my head out
and I don't see any
swimmin Oster phone
just as the train doors closed I get a
text telling me to put the phone outside
because they're stuck on the other side
of the tracks but at this point it's too
late if you open I can lose that cipher
yes it's gonna come back up
[Music]
I sent a photo so you'd know exactly
with a phone not two minutes later I get
confirmation that they picked up the
phone the whole ordeal took exactly 58
minutes so Kirk got his phone back
Stephanie and I did a good deed
BuzzFeed got a video everyone was happy
except our cat who was still pissed
[Music]